if okay lights come start immediately
lights camera action so you're the devil
and I'm Rebecca Dear Mr devil
I am to tell you my soul my heart
my mind but not my body well my body not
my body nor my mind in return
I would like a pack of cigarettes and in
my next life I want to be Kate Moss
so what is your perception here mark
what is your what is the Zoe report
you're waking up I'm woke before I spoke
bloke look at me Gin Rummy
show me what you have in your bag what
Aphrodite [__] that [__] I'm Medusa
gaga gaga gaga
oh the road just collaborated you know
Mary Kate and Ashley anyway they just
collaborated with Lulu Guinness and
Betsy [__] John's um
#no prenup
welcome back to the wedding of meditate
Ashley and Rebecca the mark of the beast
uh it's not your name Mark later
I can think of Leica that remember that
dog like a space dog I remember that you
would rather shoot with a Makita or a
Leica Pig one
I mean honestly it's so like um like
Bare Bones you know like like under the
nitty-gritty showing off them shitty
cannons like some hot
and just like that
see I just think I was a Samantha and
then it turned out I was a Carrie this
Digger in size of him well you know I
like my [__] the way I like my Italians
neat petite and ready to me see I'm very
attracted this man you heard of him Fiat
air oh he's a billionaire it Rhymes so
many crimes are gonna be committed here
because I want to produce I'm a training
too so he has been in the Press twice
once he faked his kidnapping
and then at the ugly butcher Chinese
house for a few days from Drug Money the
second time
he was with celebrity chef Marcus London
who broke up with him why because on
Marcus London's birthday or America's
government [__] his name is
he invited transgender prostitutes to
sleep with them
that is his face and she likes strange
and I'm a trying to
are you interested yes I'm a trend no
you're not yeah I got a dick and I'm
wearing a bra I'm a trend you're a
cross-dresser I'm not a contest I took
some hormones the other day you did
Ah that's five that's six
uh that's seven uh make me come come
they don't bring out an inner woman Diva
sex goddess in me I mean you are around
you and I'm always having to perform for
the people and be the little boy Becky
and just introduce myself as palatable
you know little girl lost poor little
rich girl [__] that [__] [__] I'm came
on
incarnate
it's like I didn't mean to disrespect
here I got carpeting God it's the 80s
all over again
see I've never done heroin but fabulous
for throwback I will be your hero baby I
will save you your daughters love you
beautiful daughters I'll make the models
on my life
and as um Supreme witch I offer myself
in place of your daughters to burn
eternally in hell you want to be my
third daughter oh I'm your favorite
daughter yo yo oh my god daddy oh my God
I don't like my father why honestly he's
a [__] putt see what I mean he's the
fat guy he just told me you just told me
Peter Griffin
um like like didn't know about the Xanax
smoothies hashtag
lisaic smoothies who do you prefer at
least serving or at least a Vanderpump
or Lisa Simpson
hahaha
I prefer Elisa right now and then Lisa
Vanderpump and then Lisa no offense two
of them were my daughters and one of
them is a hawk Lisa Simpson
Jessica Simpson
you're my Ellen DeGeneres see once upon
a dream that was an interview
Olsen were conjured to appear before
damn lady which Ellen DeGeneres
to advertise their perfume for Elizabeth
and James their diffusion night
Elizabeth and James White Nirvana and
it's just black for now
heroin
and cocaine interesting I do math
heroin cocaine meth
HCM
h m
fashion looking good feeling fine I'm a
victim I've tried my mind control
the CIA
is messing with my life Mark they are
prostituting me in these
these these
Grog flicks
God it's like Madonna all over again you
know what I mean
erotic
erotic sex sex like it's not just
Madonna that's gone to me you know what
I mean sex mice out to like Stephen
mazdao does not know what sex is Stephen
Klein yes
exchange the client doesn't approach sex
the way he should it's like both lack
pleasure maisel is a show-off and Klein
is a snob who do you prefer my Zeller
Klein I like them both I know me too I
want for a client usually because we all
have that complex anyone wearing fashion
or the Arts we were never the cool kid
in high school you know what I mean or
like the drama nerd you know what I mean
um honestly I think one needs to get his
dick sucked and one needs to
you know go make out with someone and
find some love in their hearts see
Madonna apparently it was really famous
on Tick Tock which I don't have see I'm
really I'm an old woman you know what I
mean I don't have a phone I don't have
an Instagram and on Facebook Twitter
nothing you know I rely on Word of Mouth
and or throw box and or you know ooh
someone's mixtape some cousin some
cousins make save from last week or
whatever but um apparently you could
during the covet no no shut up listen
with us drink open one of the most
popular songs on Tick Tock was a remix
of Frozen Which is my
you want to talk about love you want to
talk about giving your heart and soul
sacrificing yourself to God
to find your one true love
Frozen in fire
is the name of the remix
excuse me you're gonna burn after
everything she's done
I made it through the Wilderness
will happen live two nights ago hashtag
girls on the grind hashtags living and
Terry Feynman was imitating Nicole
Kidman one thing I love about Nicole is
she's always played a bad girl but like
but like a cat see Nicole and I've
learned shot I love portrait of a lady
it's a perfect introduction you know I
heard her and her father used to get it
on you know I mean it's a family cards
apparently incest is uh very
advantageous in his life interest in
Judaism go hand in hand like uh pearls
and slime
oops wait real quick could you put those
two little mics down there oops oh no
I love you mark
mark my word all this money that you
give me if I could give you if I could
like [__] flame my skin I would give
you my skin oh that's going for clothes
and wigs that's money for clothes
and cigarettes cigarettes all right
cigarettes too yeah no cigarettes are
the modest operandi Theory
I'm trying to spend too much because I
smoke
and one thing about Rachel though is I
heard she has a bit of a habit you know
but she quit for her kid
Roger but I mean apparently that's Let's
Talk About Sex well guys it's a bedroom
you don't know it's a freak in the
streets [__] you never know I'm in
the sheets I know Roger good for you
Roger honestly Roger that back to my
Juicy Couture Curts it's curtains for
you what do you think of this curtain
it's Juicy Couture [__] Juicy Couture
[__]
[Music]
no you have a dick how dare you what
else are you gonna do with it I have a
vagina behind my dick I'm an androgen I
swear
I was born a hermaphrodite determine
what do why because they were Muslims
again
how many languages do you do you speak
Arabic English and French fluently I
speak a little Russian previous
but honestly I wish I was French you
know what I mean
you know my English is perfect my Arabic
is intangible they would hate me if I
spoke at you know just because it's
really snob actually you know what I
mean my French is [__] and French people
very
beautiful and saw me both irritating
creatures on the planet I like the
parisians were even worse
love nothing more than your mind Rebecca
that she is not fluent in focus so they
always mock me see see you know a French
person's mocking you when you go up to
them you ask something in French and
they answer English it's like no [__]
I live for fashion baby
along the
way because
she's not good she is witches
how am I the Supreme because I have a
dick like the bathroom
remind me to never bring you by my house
oh Mikey Martin not if you're gonna spit
I've never stolen anything for anyone's
house the other day I swear my phone got
in my back I'm worried about you
spitting she stole it oh spinning oh
sorry it's just my uh grandmother I see
has this thing with like uh spitting so
you know it's like hereditary in the
family we're gonna give love together
it's not the first time you spit here
I'm sorry do you want me to clean it up
no no it's Skid Row you know what my DNA
is worse it's good right exactly Mark
please get a little boujee 61 million
dollars
for four what was the price
for
no we shouldn't talk about that here why
not my personal business is my personal
business
give me a give me a number
I don't believe you it's true then why
are you in the studio that's a great
question why am I all my friends are
asking me why am I doing this why are
you doing this
I'm crazy
I do crazy [__]
and the older I get the crazier I get I
think I think crazy
in love
forbidden Paradise
divine
how would you divide a forbidden
Paradise
I don't know
what do you want with this
I mean you wanted to go on camera to
speak about your daughters what do you
want out of this let me ask you a
question I'd avoid this project this
project oh I I think if we all just
understood each other better I think
that would be really great
I think it would just help Society it's
help the world
if we all understood why Rebecca is
being like she is why the drug addicts
are doing what they're doing why the
gang members are doing what they do why
the
attempts and the prostitutes are doing
what they do if we all understood each
other better we might raise our kids
differently we might treat each other
differently
they might treat ourselves differently
with love and respect is the presumption
yeah what I give is an example of how to
treat everyone with respect and kindness
that's what I try to do as well um
it's a great way to go through your life
elaborate
there's nothing to elaborate about I
just I just treat you like you are the
queen of England here
who just passed away
rest in peace
this was this was without any drugs
right the the interview we just did was
was you weren't imbibing since then
right you didn't take anything
or did you
your personality changed drastically
yeah I think he just woke up
your daughters are very beautiful by the
way
both of them
one's not
I got a bunch of great women in my life
my mom my ex-wife my kids
my girlfriends
not at the same time
scandal
I'd love to turn the camera on you and
film you for a change
I'd love a camera too
you can't even hold on to a phone
I'm ready for a phone number zero
yeah
one more bit of wisdom from Rebecca
we'll close it out
what message would you like to share
with the with the world
totally
[__] totally
okay on with the show
[Music]
ask me anything
what's your biggest secret
that you don't share with anybody
you're a very private person so that's
why
asking you this is something I wouldn't
ask anyone else
Not only would it no longer be a secret
but I'd say The Best Is Yet To Come
you've completely and utterly nosedive
to the point of
nothing but
higher hopes
is that I honestly I'm slightly more
apologetic
you can only go up from here you said it
all right that was fun
more fun that was good